[MUSIC]
I am embarrassed,
not because I am going to be stuttering
through this entire thing.
But, because I am part of this awesome
world, and
I have not had any sort, of any sort of
possible impact.
Last, last year went to India and I had
spent three days inside of,
inside of, inside of a, inside of a,
inside of a, inside of a Inside of a,
inside of a,
inside of a rural village.
With those people earning a dollar a day.
Imagine a house the size of this floor for
six people.
A roof, a roof, a roof that is going up to
your chest.
You have to squat to move anywhere.
There is no sanitation.
Three days a week you have to spread, you
have to spread,
you have to spread, you have to spread,
you have to spread,
you have to spread
the cow dung on the floor and walls as an
antibacterial.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
A place where men in their 40s have their
faces light up whenever
they're given a second piece of chocolate.
A place where kids have no way out.
I had left here feeling impassioned to try
to improve their lives.
I had wanted to be able to provide them
with education,
sanitation, and a hope for something
better.
But I am embarrassed to say that soon
after I had gotten home,
I had forgotten about these feelings.
Started to think about finding a job,
making friends,
learning finance.
[LAUGH].
I had let life stop me from the impact
that I wanted to have.
Not too long after I came across a story
about a Florida Starbucks.
About how a woman in her 60s bought coffee
for the person behind her.
What followed was a two day, 750 person
chain.
The first person bought it for the second,
the second for the third, 750 times.
And so started to think, whether there was
an easy way for me, perhaps you.
People that are not going to, people that
are not going
to, people that are going to give ow,
people that are not going to give our,
our entire lives to solving social
problems could still have an impact.
I wanted to figure out why, why, why, why,
why are people giving.
And what could stop the inertia that I had
experienced.
So I started to, so I started to like
figure this out.
And Stanford, and Stanford, and Stanford,
and Stanford,
and Stanford prof, be Stanford, Stanford,
Stanford, Stanford professor BJ Fogg has
figure out why.
We often fail with our goals, because they
are too big, and
because they are too hard.
Goals like solving poverty inside of
India.
Working out five days a week.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Flossing our teeth every night.
>> We can not go from 0 to 100 miles an
hour overnight.
We have to start small and work our way
up.
We need a gradual approach.
We are much better off helping people once
in our community.
Working out one day a week.
Flossing a single tooth.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Over time, we are gonna have the
craving to wanna do more and more.
We are gonna help people more often, work
out twice a week, three times a week.
Floss one tooth, two teeth, three teeth.
>> [LAUGH].
>> The other part about this is that we
have to start now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Research shows that as we get older and as
we get wealthier,
we start to give less time and we start to
give less money.
The focus of our causes also shift, to be
those that we are connected to.
We start giving to things like alma
maters, political candidates,
religious institutions.
And we stop giving to things around
poverty, global health,
and other social services.
Following this advice,
solving poverty inside of India was way
too big of a first step for me.
[LAUGH].
And so last year I took one small step
forward and
I gave one talk to a group of youth about
overcoming challenges as a stutterer.
This year, I took a second step forward
and thro, and like,
through and through and through a, and
through, and through a program here,
I'm help, I am helping a next convict
Josemph, Joseph on his business.
let me be clear.
This type of behavior is not gonna solve
poverty inside of India,
but it is a necessary first step.
It is about, it is all about, it is all
about,
it is all about a change inside of us.
A change towards a greater awareness, and
a greater,
change towards a greater awareness,
greater concern, greater,
and a greater, change towards a greater
concern for other people.
And this is my challenge for all of you
today.
Some of you are to, some of you are going,
some of you are going,
some of you are going, some of you are go,
or some,
some of you are going, some of you are
going, or go,
we make you spend your entire life solving
social problems.
Awesome, and thank you.
[LAUGH].
Sincerely.
For those of you who are not, we can still
have an impact.
And I'm asking you, and I'm asking you
right now, today,
to start to build that habit.
To find that something that is small,
to find that something that is extremely
easy for you.
Perhaps it's, perhaps it's, perhaps it's,
perhaps it is,
perhaps it is, like, going to be
volunteering at our local Boys and
Girls Club, or some other local
organization.
For those of us that want to start
smaller,
technology has made it really easy for us.
Apps like Charity Miles.
You can raise money for every mile you
walk around here.
Be a, Be My Eyes can spend 15 seconds
helping out,
like, a blind person navigate their
surroundings.
Or reading, or read a, or read in a, or
read in a, or read in a, the expiration
date off of like a milk cartoon.
Once you start, it is gonna be hard to
stop.
Your impact is going to grow.
You may even inspire people to follow
after you.
While we are at a school that is all about
changing lives, or chain,
about chain, about changing lives,
organizations, and the world.
I invite you to first start by changing
one life, or
possibly one organization, as you start to
change the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]